sur thierry samitier sera avec nous dans
un instant je vous le dit alors c'est
quelqu'un qu'on connaît bien thierry
mois chez les maîtres qui tournait ainsi
un sketch avec lui c'était hyper bien
passé il avait été avec moi dans une
émission de parodie il avait tourné avec
moi il joue notamment le rôle d'aymeric
du berner carton dans la série de tf1
nos chers voisins son personnage c'est
le père de famille a un peu coincé c'est
vrai qu'il est extrêmement drôle juste
avant qu'il nous rejoigne
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
affaire parce que thierry sera avec nous
dans un instant il veut nous donner sa
vérité valérie benaïm moi je suis très
embarrassée parce que lorsqu'il
lorsqu'il s'agit de deux personnes c'est
à dire un homme une femme et c'est
parole contre parole
et on ne peut pas dire que si l'un man
ou s'il autrement là en revanche il ya
quand même deux jeunes femmes qui
accusent et il ya là l'ensemble de la
troupe il ya la production il ya une
franck leboeuf qui jouait cette pièce de
théâtre qui s'est mis du côté des deux
jeunes femmes en disant que lui aussi
corroborait entre guillemets leur
version donc à minima on commence à se
dire qu'il y ait ici là il ya un petit
souci quand même choc donc donc vous
avez donc j'ai envie d'entendre sa
version sa marque parce que lui envie de
nous dire face à toutes ces accusations
qui sont plutôt nombreuses quand même ce
qui m espère c'est toujours la même
histoire il ya lui il ya besson il ya
bruel c'est toujours la même histoire il
ya un tribunal populaire les gens la
présomption d'innocence est foulée aux
pieds
c'est à dire qu'il ya des accusations d'
accord est tout de suite sur les réseaux
sociaux et dans les médias ils s'en
prennent plein la gueule
et après c'est super dur vous imaginez
s'il est innocent x
c'est horrible à dire que moi je trouve
qu'il devrait y avoir un chez par devoir
de réserve un truc ou d'un thème dirais
même d'en parler tant que l'affairé
n'est pas jugée
voilà on est un con et un vrai résultat
il va venir se battre notamment parce
qu'il souhaite rétablir sa vérité il est
souhaité nous répondre et répondre à ces
accusations matthieu delormeau n'a reçu
ici à une semaine à monsieur justement
pardon j'ai oublié son nom de la chaîne
equidia et qui apprenant rhioui qui
pendant un an et demi à est tombé en
dépression a été a été a été jugé par
effectivement le tribunal populaire n'a
plus de vie ces enfants pas tout le
monde
il a perdu quasiment toute sa vie il a
fait une dépression pour qu'on apprenne
au bout d'un an que finalement il avait
gagné son procès donc pardon je ne
défends pas à thierry samitier je ne
sais pas ce qui s'est passé peut-être
que la fille a raison mais encore une
fois les deux on est en train les filles
on est en train de le lyncher
peut-être que c'est parti pour un an ou
deux ans de procès et que ce monsieur
peut se faire vraiment peut-on une
dépression la plus totale
or que pour le moment il n'y a pas de
condamnation lors la pièce a été
suspendue en mars dernier pour les
accusations portées à l'encontre voilà
sur dossiers par an car ils savent
entier alors thierry samitier vous avez
une petite compil parce que voilà il est
dans nos chers voisins
voilà c'était c'est sur tf6 maintenant
sur tf1 aussi week-end regardez aymeric
pas s'émouvoir pour avoir des nouvelles
de ma carte bleue vos places je me
prépare à faire les cours de la semaine
alors je me suis tout à satiété avant
afin de ne pas succomber aux moult
tentation bugatti dépensière vous
devriez le savoir
c'est un truc de ménage hier alors moi
je connais une autre méthode assez mal
votre portefeuille quand j'étais scout
dès que je jouais sans piano dans la
chaleur un peu moins d'espoir de bivouac
à ces demoiselles me couvet lui regarde
tout c'est un pôle ça doit consommer
énormément
ça va faire grimper les charges
justement non monsieur lambert et c'est
là la bonne nouvelle vous êtes branché
sur le compteur de l'immeuble d'en face
c'est ça non alors ça c'est une idée qui
m'est venue en regardant un reportage
sur l'obésité infantile
je vois pas le rapport à économie
d'énergie et protection la santé de mes
enfants
ciné général jean michel maire parce que
ce que je trouve à chaque fois choquant
si ces cas là on parle d'agression
sexuelle et je trouve qu'ils les mots
doivent encore avoir un sens même qu'en
gros à la lecture du dossier c'est pas
qu'on ne parle pas de la question
sexuelle ces gens il sait et s'approcher
derrière elle on jouait un peu près sont
à changer de métier pas là c'est parce
que ce qui a été relaté
mais on ne va pas on va pas définir ici
bien sûr c'est que d'être pas là pour ça
d'entendre çà çà çà version à des gens
qui ont été témoins il ya des gens qui
ont parlé il ya des mains courantes ont
été déposés donc il ya forcément quelque
chose
maintenant est ce que c'est quelque
chose de grave ici comment ça s'est
passé il faut savoir où pour tout le
monde a parlé contre lui il faut
maintenant savoir ce qu'elle lui a vécu
et c'est vrai moi je dirais une fête
juste une chose ou deux secondes
moi je connais un peu les comédiens
parce que je n'ai fait que deux
comédiens et j'ai que parfois c'est vrai
que dans les troupes de théâtre parfois
ça rigole alors est-ce que ça rigole et
parfois ya des comportements qui font
mal interprété peut-être mais voilà je
voulais juste te dire toi gâte en fait
il faut malheureusement ou heureusement
d'ailleurs mesuré l'époque et la société
dans laquelle on vit on vit dans
l'époque de la ferme einstein en vidant
l'époque ni tout en vidant les packs
balances ton port les bienfaits et on
l'a tous soutenu ici c'est la libération
de la parole des femmes victimes etc
dérive en revanche c'est que un homme il
peut être le mieux intentionné du monde
s'il se livre à un jeu de séduction à
une drague il ça peut être extrêmement
mal interprété et dangereux donc à
savoir où se place où se placent les
coupables là dedans c'est très compliqué
rarement rapide tant qu'un jour
quelqu'un va se [ __ ] en l'air
quelqu'un qui est accusé comme ça c'est
horrible ce bail dans la rue quand on
est connu et qu'on a accusé comme ça d'
agression sexuelle imaginez ces enfants
et tout ça un jour quelqu'un va se
[ __ ] en l'air et ce jour là on va
enfin comprendre dans ce pays ce match
c'est pas du tout cette histoire je sais
moi non plus qui a tort qui a raison
mais aussi des jeunes femmes
il souffre énormément et qui peuvent
aussi pour les uns mais cyril elles ont
été agressées sexuellement dont vous
avez raison de la vue qui seront choisis
bien fait s'avérer connaissez que
l'accusation fait condamnation à nancy
oui voilà
non mesdames assure mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya des jeunes filles aussi qu'ils
peuvent vivre des moments bien ré
difficile et se [ __ ] en l'air derrière
l'excellent devrait êter voilà voilà par
une personne oui la pièce est suspendue
ce qui n'est pas rien c'est une comédie
de boulevard à succès
les gens qui ont fait qu'ils produisent
la pièce ils vont pas arrêter la pièce
comme ça par pape a rappelé comment vous
deviez continent c'est pour ça que c'est
intéressant tu sois là c'est pour ça que
c'est intéressant qu'ils soient là pour
en parler
yvan par les instants tu peux vous
donner la parole parce que jusqu'à
maintenant pardon j'ai entendu tout le
monde sauf lui
exactement alors justement thierry
samitier je vous dis c'est ça son avocat
lui a déconseillé de venir
thierry voulait absolument venir
s'exprimer thierry samitier parce que
c'est vrai comme vous avez dit il à il a
été la cible voilà de 2,2 de beaucoup
d'accusations et c'est vrai qu'il
voulait venir s'expliquer sur cette
affaire ce soir thierry samitier et
année
merci au père s'y terrer merci d'être là
merci père asseyez-vous alors thierry
syrie que vous avez voulu être avec nous
ce soir parce que ça a démarré cette
affaire c'est médiapart qui a sorti
cette affaire et vous souhaitez rétablir
la vérité et répondre à toutes les
accusations qui vous les faits qui vous
sont reprochés
paraît que vous êtes tombé des nues en
découvrant les accusations mais en
réalité je suis tombé quand j'ai reçu le
mail de médiapart
il disait quoi se mêle de médiapart
balleux mais le même qui misait est-ce
que vous souhaitez voilà on va faire un
papier sur vous relatant une agression
sexuelle
est-ce que vous souhaitez répondre donc
bien sûr j'ai j'ai souhaité répondre et
je suis arrivé au rendez vous je dirais
avec aussi un ensemble de contacts de
personnes que j'ai rencontrées de femmes
que j'ai rencontrées au cours de toute
ma vie professionnelle et il est que les
commentaires j'allais dire une de mes
témoins ont été soit soit coupées soit
modifiée par mediapart et je trouve ça
extrêmement grave parce que dans mes
témoins il ya une femme qui me connaît
par coeur donc qui sait exactement quels
gestes je peux poser est quel geste je
ne peux pas poser sur une femme qui une
femme qui a été battue violée
harcelés et qui disait dans donc à la
journaliste de mediapart que dans ces
périodes et j'allais dire dramatique
j'étais là et elle pouvait compter sur
moi et l'association de franck leboeuf
par contre je n'y étais pas donc c'est
des choses très importantes relativement
à la sphère qui ont été enlevés et
j'allais dire la défense donc elle a
terminé en disant mais madame vous êtes
en train d'organiser un lynchage et je
crois que c'est la seule phrase que la
journaliste de mediapart donc en effet
sont alors organisées dans l' enquête de
mediapart pour nos téléspectateurs les
deux actrices qui était avec eux dans la
pièce rapporte un comportement déplacé
de votre part j'étais pencher pour
accéder au miroir
thierry est arrivé derrière et a collé
son sexe contre mes fesses en me disant
pourquoi tu as peur de moi avec un ton
pervers il grillé au début c'étaient des
compliments sauf qu'il a commencé à être
tactile une fois thierry est arrivé
derrière et a collé son sexe contre mes
fesses qu'est ce que vous répondez à ces
accusations je réponds que c'est
absolument faux et que je vivais un
début d'histoire d'amour avec ma
compagne j'ai souhaité qu'elle soit
présente à l'est derrière dans le sur le
plateau avec eux c'est un moment où on
faisait l'amour trois fois par jour là
on est descendu à un mois qu'on a on a
baissé au niveau de l'intensité
si vous voulez mais je je je conteste
totalement cette ces allégations il ya
une chose que je ne conteste pas c'est
que à la fin d'une répétition il ya une
comédienne qui a été vraiment
fantastique je verrai aussi tu es tout à
l'heure un petit peu le contexte parce
que en fait il y avait la famille
metteur en scène il y avait la femme du
tourneur il y avait une actrice imposé
s'occupe de la tournée donc on absolue
doit tourner imposé par franck leboeuf
et sert qu'il n'y avait pas de alors
qu'on a fait auditionner 50 comédienne
ça ira on a fait venir 50 comédienne à
paris de strasbourg de lille parfois des
comédiennes qu'on pas d'argent on leur a
fait passer une audition
alors que les rôles étaient déjà squatté
je suis la mieux vous un complot vous
pensez contre vous sinon l'allèle je
parle de la mise en place si vous avez
l'air de l'équipe c'est des rires équipe
un peu particulière
un particulière qui qui m'a tout de
suite orthez c'est à dire que l'on fait
pas passer des auditions à des comédiens
si l'on prend la fin du metteur en scène
on dit bah ouais ça sera une femme du du
metteur en scène c'est à dire que c'est
vrai que j'ai pas été à l'aise tout de
suite dans dans la sphère mais en ce qui
concerne en ce qui concerne les
accusations
c'est vrai que un record pour quoi elle
aurait fait ça qu'elle est calé quel est
leur intérêt alors il s'est passé en
fait c'est cédric elles n'ont jamais eu
de problème non plus elle aussi alors
vous savez ce qui se passe quand je
rappelle que donc ils y avaient leurs
hommes dans l'équipe c'est tard que moi
ce que ce que je comprends pas c'est que
tu harcèle ma nana alors que je suis
tourneur de la pièce je viens de
démonter la gueule mais en trois
secondes dont il faut m'expliquer un
petit peu tu vois dans six mois excuse
moi deuxièmement le harcèlement sexuel
est extrêmement grave si ça va pas en
main courante moi j'attaque en justice
c'est à dire je porte plainte à ok j'y
suis je vous le rappelle aux
téléspectateurs un courant qui a pas eu
certes l'attaquant justice ait eu deux
mois courant mais je ne comprends pas et
pourquoi ça sort huit mois plus tard
c'est à dire que lorsque il ya une
agression sexuelle
moi c'est immédiatement parce que le
type il va continuer a agressé
sexuellement d'autres femmes
donc quand aussi à une agression tout de
suite je vends justice je comprends pas
le la manigance mais alors vous dites si
vous vous dites que franck leboeuf
voilà qui en plus quelqu'un que j'aime
beaucoup un joli voilà quiquet et qui
s'est toujours bien passé
lui dit il confirme avoir été témoin des
comportements inappropriés
2 ne venant de votre part en le
rappelant il vous a rappelé plusieurs
fois à l'ordre ses skis dit j'ai vu
alice sortir de scène en tremblant et en
disant à thierry d'arrêter de mettre la
langue lors de leurs scènes de baisers
j'ai dit à thierry mais tu es un grand
malade toi va falloir que tu arrêtes tu
sais que je défends une association qui
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes et frank leboeuf a rapporté à
mediapart un sms surprenant qui vous a
adressée pour alller pour relativiser
les faits qui lui sont reprochés il m'a
dit que tout était faux qu'il était
homosexuel et que pour lui embrasser des
femmes c'était comme embrasser des
merdes de chiens c'est le sms de thierry
samitier rapportés par franck leboeuf
alors on voit qu'on voit que ça c'était
c'était face un essai mais c'est une
connerie que nous lui avons envoyé le
nom ce qui se passe c'est que un soir
une comédienne sort de scène et devant
donc dans le plateau derrière 10 ha ha
devant tout le monde
tammy la langue et frank leboeuf au lieu
de me retirer at environ va discuter
parce que là devant toute l'équipe lui
répond me répond non à thierry sa
tension cher président d'une association
de femmes battues tellement surréaliste
mais surréalisme et moi dans une
situation surréaliste j'envoie une
connerie c'est rare que je réponds pas
par un truc qui me complètement débile
par un truc sérieux
je suis vraiment désolé alors vous dites
si vous devez faire votre autocritique
critique vous reconnaissez voir avoir
été lourd ou excessif dans l'humour
c'est ce que vous dites non jeu excessif
dans le sens c'est vrai qu'il ya une une
répétition ou une comédienne justement
la seule comédienne castet c'est à dire
est qu'il était légitime dans la sphère
a été mais un magnifique m'a fait hurler
de rire et c'est pas facile d'être juste
avec un accent anglais en fait c'est
dans la presse anglaise est donc l
ranger son vélo juge les prises par le
coup jeudi a été vraiment tu as été
vraiment génial mais d'inventer que j'ai
connue alors qu'on était en hiver on et
j'étais en parka que j'ai collé mon sexe
machin chouette mais c'est c'est un truc
de fou de joie je vous repose la
question tout le monde se pose est que
tous les téléspectateurs secondes quel
est l'intérêt de ces deux jeunes filles
de faire ça voilà dit moi alors
attention derrière ces deux jeunes
filles il ya un homme il ya un homme
c'est franck leboeuf
oui et penser que franck leboeuf vous en
veut parce que francs que je connaisse
c'est un garçon que charvaux choix
pourquoi il se fait chier à vous
alors moi et moi je vais vous raconter
une chose d'accord c'est un garçon
charmant j'ai je fais partie d'une
association qui s'appelle ela qui lutte
contre la leucodystrophie et dont le
super parent c'est design eddine zidane
bien sûr et donc un jour jean-claude
sata dentier le qui est le chef des
parrains on va dire le dit thierry est
ce que ça t'intéresse de venir faire un
match de foot avec les anciens de 98
avec zidane et toute la bande et je suis
dit ma four la caisse je viens avec
franck leboeuf
je commence une pièce avec lui dans un
mois 1000 1 1 en titane
là l'équipe là ils veulent pas de franck
leboeuf je suis étonné parce que le mec
est super c'est un amour dessin poterie
série club
c'est vraiment apple est fini je je je
je suis étonné parce que hein parce que
le mec est super cool super soft patrie
et je croise pierre menez tu sais c'est
un journaliste sportif que je connais un
petit peu de téloche je lui dis je je je
joue bientôt avec ton pote parce que je
sais qu'ils sont tous les deux
chroniqueurs sportifs
je joue bientôt avec ton pote et 1
et il me dit non non non le boeuf c'est
pas mon pote et ça m'étonne pas ce que
je te dis en début de début d'histoire
je trouve
vous aurez envie et bien au début avec
franck leboeuf au début au début mais
après vous entendiez play parfaitement
mais ça a vrillé ce avrillé de façon
progressive m'accorde thierry donc vous
pour vous c'est un complot de ses deux
filles mené par franck leboeuf qui vous
aime pas c'est ça ben vous savez il
rappelé a été arrêté je ne sais pas
l'intérêt de franck leboeuf aussi
d'arrêter là je vais vous dire je vais
vous dire un truc un peu violent c'est
que je suis venu de normandie
et hier soir j'ai eu un coup de fil avec
ma compagne est parce qu on était bien
sûr on est sous le choc et renault c'est
d'une violence mais insupportable et
c'est pour ça que ça va pas s'arrêter là
j'ai ma compagne m'a dit tu sais c'est
un rien finalement il ya un il ya les
derrière vous en votre compagnie
dernièrement et m'a dit tu sais tirer
finalement il ya un point commun entre
frank leboeuf et hitler c'est gros c'est
que ce sont deux artistes ratés
c'est à dire que franck leboeuf aloès et
cdc c'est un grand club et a été un
grand footballeur mais excuse moi sur
scène bas il joue comme un pied et c'est
normal c'est un football m et là alors
la série qu'un virulent mais thierry
vous laissez faire une ce genre de
comparaison ça vraiment ça c'est le
genre de truc qui me fait pas du tout
rire ce genre de comparaison sur hitler
on est assez s'est passé mes journées se
saouler peau contrebande a commencé à
jouer au téléphone je nous arrive le
taureau peureux non mais je sais mais
vous pouvez pas dire ça l'antenne n'en
est pas con paris franck leboeuf à
hitler sanaa n'ont vraiment la pause sur
lui non mais je te jeter gens qui jouent
r&b pour tous les gens voient la grille
qui connaissent l'histoire on pouvait
pas comparer
franck leboeuf est claire là c'est
extrêmement violents et donc voilà bon
alors ça peut être un truc que vous êtes
dire je sais que vous pouvez être
bien sûr rejeté par tout ce qui vous
arrive à on échange et là on va trop
loin on est choqués on est choqué par la
violence par la violence globale qui
s'est déchaînée contre nous et qui sont
souvent qui sont souvent des recopie
d'article c'est un des copier-coller
l'article qui centre mais et je vais
sortir mais je trouve nujiang quand même
est d'une telle violence pourrait vous
rendez compte que ça vous décrédibilise
totalement quoi comprendre votre avocat
vous avez des frênes n'aura pas fois
battu à la scie à l'image de la
différence qu'il avait dedans mais si
c'est pour faire des tresses a cédé à
vous soyez totalement d'en reverser moi
je vais la sortir des juges je veux dire
une chose et j'ai une maman qu'à 82 ans
j-11 j'ai un nom j'ai un papa qui avait
été un mec droit est un mec vrai et là
on a sali mon nom d'une façon et d'une
violence et que je n'ai que toi tu n'as
jamais vécu dans ta vie non personne sur
ce plateau n'a jamais vécu dans sa vie
et donc je vais me défendre et je dirais
peut-être des choses terribles mais je
vais me défendre dirige les charges sans
n'a jamais remis en doute les choses ce
qui a été dit par les joutes les choses
sont laisse vous laisse la parole vous
voulez c'est donner votre vérité mais
c'est vrai que là c'est pareil on est un
petit peu maladroite et violente ans et
maladroite et malheureuse jeu c'est
maladroit je m'en excuse mais ce que la
signification
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que on
est sur un plateau et je pense que je
pense qu'il a un rêve
franck leboeuf c'est d'être reconnu en
tant que comédien et que ce rêve ne se
réalise pas et que pour lui c'est
compliqué et que pour lui c'est
difficile donc derrière derrière tout
c'est un amalgame de mensonges il ya
quelqu'un qui kiffent roman tout ça et
je pense que c'est pas terminé puisque
j'ai des amis avec qui j'ai joué qu on
est venu voir et à qui on a dit avec
thierry samitier ya pas il n'y a pas eu
il n'y a pas eu assé patassé banon non
attends mais il n'y a pas eu tu te
souviens pas de dons qu'il ya peut-être
des lapins qui vont sortir du chapeau je
vous préviens l'ailé les affaires à
risque de continuer on va parages à main
c'est énorme que ce soit c'est un énorme
complot ouais tragique pour vous parce
que ça veut dire qu'il ya une personne
qui décide de vous mettre à mort et de
ruiner ma carrière et je vois pas son
intérêt parce que presque autant franck
et c'est un pote aussi donc c'est un
excellent footballeur
il commençait car les comédiens je ne le
vois pas se mettre en rang en prise
montbrison avec vous très honnêtement
maintenant c'est possible et si c'est
donc si c'est faux c'est dramatique pour
lui et c'est lui
doit être qu il est poursuivi et
condamné et eau et l inverse c'est ce
qu'il dit est vrai c'est vous qui est
dans les cieux sont repiqués donc vous
comment vous pouvez vous situer dans le
temps entre le complot à la question est
ce ce phénomène de société ou maintenant
malheureusement un comportement pour
déconner inappropriée peut déraper parce
qu'effectivement et jeu honnêtement je
le dis tous les gars on peut peut-être
pas tous moi je moi je peux je peux le
dire parfois on a des gestes ou on
déconne et ça peut déraper et devrait
interpréter c'est évident qu'on l'a tous
fait cyril et moi et moi le premier
trophée denery non mais je fais est
juste si bien qu'aujourd'hui si bien
qu'aujourd'hui on est tous à la merci un
jour pour avoir eu pour avoir déconné
pour en faire un naze et qui était mal
interprétés tu retrouvé avec une main
courante
derrière nous au pire un procès mais
dans votre cas vous ça semble beaucoup
plus compliqué c'est ce que je voulais
vous dire voilà le benjamin ce que ce ce
que je voulais dire c'est que tu vois
dans une histoire comme ça il ya une
espèce de dramaturgie c'est à dire de
petits éléments qui peuvent envenimer
j'allais dire qu'une situation et tu
vois par exemple début de l'histoire on
est tous potes ça se passe super bien je
t'appelle mon coco tu m'appelles ma
cocotte
ouais mon coco ça vaille machin est au
bout de six mois ça commence à avrillé
et tu veux tu viens bien et tu me dis
mais attend il ya six mois tu m'appeler
tu m'appeler ma cocotte c'est vrai bah
oui oui c'était dans l'énergie nathan
laisse moi finir c'était dans l'énergie
de ce qu'on vivait c'était danse étaient
dans l'euphorie de notre donnerez à nous
dans des histoires à ce propos là et je
hais je vous le dire que moi j'ai des
amis qui ont été harcelés sexuellement
et qui me disent mais sa cause de nanas
comme ça que notre voix un jour se fera
plus entendre parce que si tu viens
d'énoncer du harcèlement sexuel en
permanence partout à la télé dans les
médias un jour il ya une fille qui sera
vraiment souffrance et qu'on n'en
coûtera plus juste les séries
qu'est ce que vous répondez quant à ces
habitations c'est complètement fou
j'étais pencher pour accéder au miroir
tir est arrivé derrière a collé son sexe
contre mes fesses en me disant pourquoi
tu as peur de moi avec un ton pervers il
rit est ce qu'elle est vrai cette scène
d'abord est-ce que tu imagines est-ce
que tu imagines dans cette situation tu
vois non
non mais c'était non non ce que je veux
dire c'est que tu vois moi je je je peux
être quand je suis lourd c'est lourd par
la poésie d'accord donc j'espère que je
peux te dire excuse moi mais je trouve
que tu as splendeur et ta profondeur
ressemble à cette rivière que j'avais
connu mais il m'est jamais par un geste
mais par un pas mais par un geste ou pas
et ma compagne peux te dire je suis pas
un tactile
je ne suis pas quelqu'un de temps vous
vous dites que ces jeunes filles ont
inventé ça oui alors oui au début
c'étaient des compliments sauf qu'il a
commencé à être active elle et vous donc
le jeu non je ne suis pas un tactile
alors c'est ce qu'elle dit une joie de
gérer est arrivé derrière que je
souhaite c'est que je connaissais elles
disent la même chose en fait les deux
séries le oui non mais je vous dis moi
qui ai dit voilà c'est fait je suis un
jeu tient en amical c'est à dire que
quand quelqu'un mais je ne suis pas un
tactile car que je peux je peux prendre
par l'épaule je peux mais me coller mon
sexe machin chouette je n'ai jamais va
les réviser
je comprends tout à fait que vous venez
ici sur ce plateau défendre votre
honneur et votre nom et c'est simplement
moi je suis extrêmement basique comme
fille moi je lis dans la presse et je
lis que deux jeunes femmes visiblement
disent la même chose à votre rencontre
qu un troisième compagnon de route entre
guillemets vient corroborer donc à tout
le moins on s'interroge et on se dit
mais quelle serait leur raison de mentir
parce que non seulement je peux jouer
mon pascal fallais met à mal elle aussi
puisque finalement le résultat tout ça
c'est bien sûr il n'ya plus elle leur
nom final est sorti aussi la pièce
s'arrête donc on s'interroge du pourquoi
du comment pourquoi est-ce qu'il
mentirait et ont très récemment dans la
boue voilier mais au kerry a répondu que
je pourrai pointures je peux répondre
il ya dans cette dramaturgie qu'on a
vécu il ya eu un élément particulier
c'est que le producteur et le metteur en
scène me convoque à l'hôtel marriott qui
ce que je trouve donc rue de la paix et
le dise voilà thierry l'année prochaine
et on va relancer la pièce franck et sa
copine véronique partent en tournée on
vire les trois hôtesses et on ne garde
que toi et c'est à partir de là à partir
de ce moment que les choses à ont
commencé on commençait avrillé et et où
les
on rit disent pas les produits à l'heure
de cette affaire alors aujourd'hui dont
ils disent quoi les producteurs alors je
suis extrêmement surpris parce que les
producteurs de cette affaire dit ce que
je sais tu te tapes à l'article de
mediapart j'ai été extrêmement surpris
alors il ya aussi les dessous des
affaires qui avez vous défendre pas
alors non mais il ya hélène lévy lac et
co auteur et metteur en scène de la
pièce de thierry qui dit elle elle vous
a défendu adil un caractère farfelu
il est particulier mais il n'a jamais
été déplacé au niveau sexuel à mon égard
c'est un déconneur potache mais
quelqu'un de respectueux il peut être
relou mais il n'y a rien du point de vue
sexuel ça c est hélène lévy qui est donc
co metteur en scène du spectacle
voilà qui a travaillé avec vous oui
pardon sauf que ce qu'hélène lévy dit on
le voit un peu et si oui comment
jugez-vous pardon judy quinn
il a l'air comme ça qu'on te voit son
plateau moi ya deux choses qui
m'étonnent la première tu dit jeudi dans
la presse boy c'est un petit peu facile
la première c'est que pourquoi elle
dépose une main courante
est ce que ça veut pas dire qu'elles ont
aussi peur d'un procès quand on fait un
procès on peut le perdre une main
courante ont déposé une main courante
pour quoi elles seraient elles vont pas
plus loin
si effectivement elles ont été agressées
petit 1 en revanche petit 2 j'ai du mal
à comprendre ce que vous avez pu faire
il ya pas que cette histoire de zidane
ridicule qu'est-ce que vous avez bien pu
faire phrase franck leboeuf pour si ce
que vous dites est vrai déclenché pardon
mais fly l'opération qui est horrible
c'est ne jamais avoir les voûtes
l'équipe avec lui est fait vous faire
tomber pour harcèlement sexuel qui fait
quoi et alors ce qui s'est produit donc
dans cette histoire pas si on sait que
lorsque il ya eu cette fameuse crise
pour le désir est à milan attention j'ai
une association de femmes battues terre
que sa posture immédiate
sap a été tirée en jouant ensemble je
voudrais qu'on parle dans sa loge pour
voir ce qui se passe
sa posture immédiate ça a été une
posture de chevalier blanc
c'est alors que j'ai une association de
femmes battues attention et ça a été sa
posture et moi j'ai pas arrivé et je
vais vous dire une chose c'est que moi
au début j'étais super content de jouer
avec lui et je suis très très admirative
des sportifs de haut niveau parce que je
sais le prix que ça coûte d'être un
sportif de haut niveau c'est un
sacrifice d'une vie et de sa vie mais
c'est pour ça que j'étais hyper fier de
jouer avec lui alors
d parfois j'ai je vais poser des
questions et c'est drôle je me souviens
de questions je lui demande combien de
temps tu mangeais avant de jouer
ouais 3 3 heures enfin j'essaie et
d'enclencher un truc et c'était c'était
très froid c'est à dire que c'était une
espèce de posture et je pense qu'il y
avait il ya en lui
certainement une dirait une frustration
vis-à-vis du métier de comédien
parce qu'il se rend compte que ça me
semble alors injuste qui rit vous avez
dit parce que ça ça a commencé par ça
cette histoire vous devez faire un
baiser dans la pièce et vous êtes sortie
et vous a dit tu as mis la langue là que
la comédie avec vous aviez mis la langue
et vous avez dit oui c'était c'était ce
n'était pas voulu de votre part mais dit
oui j'ai mis la langue mais c'était
voilà par accident non attendez dans la
pièce il y avait trois baisers dans un
baiser on arrache le journal et on tombe
dessus et on embrasse donc j'ai pris des
coups de boule
mais j'ai pris des coups donné et j'ai
pris des coups de langue
j'ai pris des coups de tous il y avait
trois baisers en tout c'était trois
baisers il y avait un autre où elle me l
m'embrouille les cheveux et elle le mail
mais elle m'embrasse donc et c'était
toujours dans l'énergie de la comédie
ster et et c'est dans cette énergie là
mais quand vous voulez tuer un chien
vous dit qu'il a la rage
et là c'est ce qui est en train de se
passer aujourd'hui voilà est-ce que vous
parce que vous avez dit j'ai c'est un
accident
j'ai mis en avant mais c'est un accident
parce que quoi c'est donc c'est de là
que c'est parti cette histoire mais le
problème c'est que dans ces situations
on n'est plus dans une hystérie de
comédiens faire l'hystérique comédien
c'est oit [ __ ] machin chouette f égard
j'ai une association de femmes battues
et à chaque fois on n'a jamais pu avoir
une discussion
j'allais dire poser pour se dire les
choses il ya un problème avec quelqu'un
pour une discussion posée agathe et du
coup quelles sont les suites judiciaires
à cette affaire parce que tu dis que tu
vas te défendre et c'est alors il paraît
que vous allez attaquer en justice pour
diffamation
bien sûr alors vous allez attaquer ces
deux jeunes filles en justice alors
voilà voilà ce qui se passe alors pour
ge energy
qu'est ce qu'on va faire j'étais en gt
en normandie
hier matin je suis en train d'écrire un
film qui s'appelle pare-chocs et
je j'étais en normandie et hier c'était
qui pourrait donc j'ai pas pu parler de
parler à mon avocat je l'eus ce matin au
téléphone pour lui dire que c'est quoi
ta vocation pour les dire que vous tirez
pour lui dire que vous me proposiez
devenir d'accord donc finalement je suis
venu mais il est évident et je suis j'ai
pris ma voiture je suis nue mais il est
évident qu'il va y avoir des poursuites
ah c'est vous allez attaquer ces jeunes
femmes à cette calomnie à l'attaqué
déjouée gect qui est pas seulement parce
qu'il ya les attaques écrit alors qui
relie il ya aussi les journaux attention
vous allez attaquer en effet sur nos
formations publiques
je veux dire j'emploie venir les lattes
attendez attendez pour l'instant je n'ai
pas eu de discussion avec mon avocat en
ce qui concerne les modalités de la taxe
que nous allons émettre mais par contre
il est évident que ça ne va pas en reste
et chérie je vais changer votre angle d
attaque pas d'âme parce qu'en fait
médias pas ce sont les meilleurs
journalistes de france je comprends je
comprends qu'on serre et si moi je le
dis je le reconnais ça veut dire et les
meilleurs jours c'est définir france
donc il ya quelque chose comme règlement
de comptes à ok corral l'infa condé ça
va pas aller avec des gens qui sont
vraiment d'un niveau intellectuel et qui
traite les choses d'une façon assez
sérieuse et de façon vraiment prudente
et travailler si vous faites c'est
défendable c'est intéressant c'est on se
bat on se défendre les montres dans le
mail à vous entrez dans la cour des
grands ben justement mais c'est vrai
qu'on y apparaît justement
attention tout jouer je remplissais
environ dans une carrière où faut
rentrer dans la cour des grands ce sera
maintenant alors on est on espère pour
tout cas donc vous nous dites ce soir
que vous allez attaquer donc je veux je
vous dis que je vais avoir une
conversation pour l'instant la seule
conversation nous ayons eue c'est savoir
si je venais ici attrait je vous répète
mon avocat n'étaient pas d'accord moi je
trouve
m'exprimer la deuxième une discussion
qu'on va voir ce soir c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait très bien vous nous direz
voilà ce que tf1 réagit
oui c'est quand même important mais je
ne sais pas je ne pense pas parce que
pour l'instant vous avez des tournages
de calais pour nos chers voisins des les
tournages entre mecs j'adore radio dire
que les épisodes convoyeur ils ont trois
jours le vrai il ya des mecs qui sont de
passage de quarante trois séries c'est
un truc nouvelle média sas assure jean
prat osasuna s'est peut-être pas mais la
partie je voulais donner une petite
précision quand même un jeu durant toute
cette durant toute cette période
nous sommes allés tous les samedis dîner
au restaurant avec donc les comédiennes
et avec franck leboeuf et et que moi si
j'ai un jour je me fait harceler
sexuellement
je n'irai pas le samedi dîner avec le
leader de la troupe ouais c'est ça aussi
attention d'après moi un bon argument
voilà la voilà merci en tout cas thierry
je suis vraiment je suis vraiment je
vous remercie vraiment de m'avoir
accueilli et et merci à tous on voulait
avoir votre vérité après on sait pas
voilà quelle est la vérité dans cette
histoire comme à chaque fois mais vous
vouliez vous dire d'eux et que vous
exprimez unis si ce soit merci de
l'avoir fait sommes en direct bien
entendu et ça continue merci qui risque
d'avoir été avec lui
[Applaudissements]